salut romain ça va mais qu'est-ce qu'il
ya beaucoup de films dandinant de ponzi
comme ça va si on n'est pas à 100
minutes pour tourner je t'attends ah
ouais la fameuse théorie des vannes ans
moins fort vous connaissez l'histoire
vous êtes dans un environnement festif
vous buvez une bière de bière trois
bières et soudain il faut aller
jusqu'ici rien d'anormal sauf que
quelques minutes plus tard à peine les
mêmes
est ce que c'est vraiment le premier
pipi qui ouvre les vannes
est ce que si on se retient on fera
moins pipi ça j'ai l'impression que
c'est alors je vous propose de voir les
choses dans l'ordre donc déjà pourquoi
on urine
comment ça marche quand tout se passe
normalement les reins filtrent le sang
et fabrique le pipi leur job haut rhin
c'est de garder la quantité d'eau et de
minéraux dont l'organisme a besoin pour
fonctionner et d'évacuer tout le reste
avec différents autres déchets lure in
past des reins à la vessie grâce aux sur
terre elle est stockée dans la vessie en
attendant d'être évacués par l'urètre
l'évacuation elle se fait grâce à la
contraction du muscle de la vessie qui
est le muscle qui a le nom le plus cool
du corps humain parce qu'on dirait un
nom de pokémon badass il s'appelle le
détruisant en moyenne sur une journée
classique on évacue entre un litre et
demi et 2 litres d'uriné
voilà ça c'est la base mais qu'est ce
qui déclenche l envie de faire pipi
c'est croquignolette mais c'est presque
comme pour l' envie de déféquer on voit
presque dire que c'est du liquide est en
jeu
si vous ne savez pas comment ça marche
l'envi de déféquer bah écoutez c'est que
vous n'avez pas lu mon lit et je vous
cache pas que je suis vexé commencé mais
bon bref la vessie donc elle se remplit
au fur et à mesure et la sortie est
verrouillé par des cinqueterre
elle peut contenir environ six cent
millilitres mais dès qu'elle atteint 300
millilitres sa paroisse distants et les
nerfs transmettent l'information au
cerveau qui déclenche l'envi de faire
pipi pour faire de la place à ce stade
ça reste gérable on peut encore se
mettre à chercher des toilettes dans
plus grandes écoles si on attend encore
la vessie continue de se remplir
et quand on arrive à 400 millilitres on
est déjà un petit peu moins serein et a
cinq ou six cent millilitres
là ça devient carrément douloureux et il
vaut mieux entretenir des terrains sauf
que là on n'est pas dans des conditions
normales
on est à la pierre et si vous vous
souvenez bien je vous en ai déjà parlé
dans ma vidéo sur la gueule de bois
quand on boit de l'alcool on urine plus
de liquide qu'on n'en absorbe et pour ça
qu'après on est déshydratée
en fait ce qui se passe c'est que
l'alcool bloque la fabrication d'une
hormone qui s'appelle l'hormone anti
diurétiques ou vasopressine et qui
permet normalement de réabsorber une
partie de l'eau au niveau des reins du
coup là comme elle le fait pas tout
passe dans la vessie et la quantité du
rin augmente
ok mais alors pourquoi la bière plus que
le reste est bien parce que là lierse
est un peu d'alcool dans beaucoup de
liquide pour remplir sa vessie aussi
vite avec du whisky il faut en voir des
caisses et là du coup on part plus sur
un coma éthylique que sur une orbite
sertic voir un coma éthylique et vous
fait pipi dessus alors ça règle le
problème mais franchement je conseille
donc pour résumé voilà ce qui se passe
vous buvez de la bière donc vous
introduisez des grandes quantités de
liquide dans votre organisme
et comme ce liquide contient de l'alcool
vous augmenter encore la quantité du rin
que vous produisez mais tout ça ça se
passe progressivement donc au début de
la soirée
tout est normal par contre au moment où
vous commencez à avoir envie de faire
votre premier pipi le travail de sape
il a déjà commencé vous avez déjà des
verbes avance et pour rappel une pinte
c'est quand même 500 millilitres à c'est
presque une vessie et comme en plus
l'alcool a commencé à agir sur votre
hormones antidiurétique du coup la
deuxième envie de faire pipi elle arrive
beaucoup plus vite et les suivantes de
plus en plus vite parce que votre vessie
elle se remplit de plus en plus vite
en plus de ça l'alcool et les boissons
gazeuses ça aurait tendance à irriter
notre vessie à la rendre hyperactive
comme les enfants dans super nanny sauf
que là ça n'a rien à voir ça veut juste
dire que on a envie de faire pipi alors
que notre vessie n'est pas encore plein
mais il ya aucune histoire de vannes qui
s'ouvre là dedans rien du tout alors
vous allez quand même trouver des
articles qui conseille de se retenir
avant de faire son premier clip
non seulement ça sert à rien mais en
plus c'est dangereux d'abord parce que
quand on se retient urines et stagne
dans la vessie et ça augmente les
risques d'infections urinaires ou de
formation de calculs les calculs c'est
des petits cristaux dans les reins ça
pique je vous jure on voulait pas
seulement en plus se retenir trop
souvent au delà du raisonnable ça peut
distendre l'avait fille est abîmé les
muscles les nerfs et les cinqueterre
et à terme provoquer des problèmes comme
la rétention urinaire dans certains cas
extrêmes comme la rétention urinaire
réguler la miction peut être
complètement bloquée ah oui la miction
la mission c'est juste le fait de faire
pipi
voilà donc vous avez compris dans ces
cas là c'est miction impossible et non
seulement c'est très douloureux mais la
solution va pas vous clair non plus
parce que ça consiste à vider la vessie
avec une sonde qu'on introduit par le
méat urinaire a breaké le maire le mea
c'est le trou de l'urètre par lequel le
pipi sort normalement sauf que là le mea
culpa bon mais sans aller jusque là
forcément sans penser à toutes les
complications possibles
retenez que ça ne sert à rien de se
retenir
justement vous vous torturer pour rien
vous buvez vous pissez point barre alors
évidemment le mieux c'est de ne pas voir
ou de boire raisonnablement mais bon je
vous connais et puis si vous êtes là
entre regarder cette vidéo l'ajustement
ya bien une raison donc je vous remets
en barre d'infos les liens vers les
vidéos sur la gueule de bois
le black out et l'alcoolisme 1 vous
irait jusqu'à un petit coup d'oeil et je
voulais sur ces deux conseils manger
avant de voir et prenez un verre de soft
entre eux
chaque verre d'alcool voilà à détester
c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos
d'ici là prenez soin de vous et prenez
soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]